那今天我们第二个部分其实是围绕着Bear的一个成长然后大概准备了一些问题会跟他进行一个探讨当然大家可能之前同学也知道然后今天的话因为我们主题分享部分的话因为Bear他只是说应该是比较粗的地度去把整个自己的一个夸张技术的眼镜做了一下大概的介绍那我们在这个过程中其实也会对这个整个分享做一下延伸然后对某些问题做一些更深入的探讨OK
那首先第一个问题肯定是因为因为BL它现在其实是走跨平台的一个路线嘛那其实很想了解一下就是BL你当初是为什么去选择做跨平台的一个方向呢嗯ok其实最初做的时候是之前在滴滴的时候那时候之所以说也是团队的一个就是人效一个问题吧对然后当时我们去就是去探索了就是儿的将那个方向然后也是目的是为了去
再保持双端一次基础然后去提升整体的一个人效度嗯ok 那你你就是你自己当时选择做这个就是跨平台的这种开发者当时的想法是什么对那个是属于考虑人效嘛就对你自己来说嗯ok 其实我是觉得有一点比较好的一点的话就是首先我们就是往后来说因为所有的其实在做呃就是端策同学来说其实也都是在面向做一个圈嘛对
那么其实这时候大家需要对渲染的一个流水线那么能有一个非常清晰的一个认知对了解到就是渲染它本质是什么然后在此基础上的话其实就可以去做到一个化其他平台的这样一个渲染的一个拓展那么因为再加上其实不管就是未来的整体的一个交互博士是如何的去一个变化的那么实际本质上来说那么大家其实都是在面向在面向去做一个渲染的
那么只不过说可能说我们再往前推减那么以前是可能说是那种windows 奉獲的windows mobile那种那种那个就是手机然后以及再往前的一些有时候像windows pc 这样子那么其实整体上来说他们其实都是选那么只不过说对这个不同的这样的一个端选了一个方案对那么只不过说现在来说的话那么
就是做跨平台可以更好地去理解渲染的它这两个本质以及它是如何去构建就是我们所写的每一行的这样的一个呃代码的这样的一个锣链然后以最终它是如何渲染在屏幕上的对那么其实对往后来说那么其实呃不管它是OS 13之外的还是说其他的就是平台了那其实只要理解其中本质对那么其实都是可以做一个很好的一个拓展的ok所以当时选这个方向其实你更多的还是说想通过这种
做跨端的方向然后去更好的了解整个底层的一些渲染机制对吧所以他选择了这样的一个方向那另外我想问一下就是我我理解就是不要你最早应该也不是说就开始做跨端嘛对吧然后你其实应该也是从一个新手开发者然后慢慢的成长我现在说在跨端领域可能有的比较深入的研究那你在这个过程中经历的哪些成长阶段呢然后每个阶段你觉得比较关键的或者说比较重要的一些事情是什么
是可以介绍一下吗嗯ok那么其实最初的时候呃包括我理解其实包括所有的就是做跨平台同学最初的时候应该也都是在做就是端端平台的对那么那么其实最初到现在来说的话那么刚才提到就是之前以前在滴滴那时候落地而然然后那时候也是初步进行的一个跨平台证据对然后当时也是了解到其中的一个流程和原理然后其实
那个时候其实最初的点的话就是感受到了双端不一致带来一个痛苦对那么其实那个点对于前端或者说对于做那个方案就是开发的同学来说那么其实都是非常难受的对那么要去做很多的一些兼容对那也就是那段时间就是发达当时有了一个就是就是与列斯巴当时对大概1718年的时候对那么当时发达的话他提出一点的话就是他直接
去抹冰药多的那个差异性那么他直接对接到就是渲染者对那么当时也是去探索了一下Flasher对那么其实经过那段时间呢让你一个探索的话其实是发现Flasher当中其实有非常多的一些思路是可以去做一个借鉴的对其实我理解从那个过程来说我觉得更多的是一个思考吧就是可能说思考到这个方案他所能带来的价值是什么以及他对于
解决问题来说它能解决的一些核心的一些问题然后嗯对于就实际的业务场景来说或者对于开发者同学来说他能够带来一些帮助的那么其实也是还有包括之前其实呃去做了相关的一些就是短能力建设的话那也是其实逐步的去对跨平台全局的话有了一个全景视角的这样的一个思考吧那么也是经过这些思考的话然后其实
逐步的去不斷去体验自己对于相关的这样的一些就是价格分层设计的一些看法对然后不断去就是对相关的一个谋快以及每个方面然后如何去做优化对然后有了一些就是自己的一些思考和想法嗯ok对因为我我知道就是你之前最早是在滴滴吗
就是做夸钻石在滴滴刚才讲到那刚才有纯丽同学问就是对于滴滴的这个自言框架这个Hummer是Hummer还是HummerHummer吧就是你觉得他大概是什么样的一个就从你现在来看觉得他的整个项目是怎么样子的嗯ok嗯这个其实是当时那个就是皮带他对于当时在做的一个方案对那么其实嗯对我来说的话其实我觉得
更多的其实是在做一个就是一个平台产业的一个抹平嘛对那么其实在往后其实我觉得可以更往就是底层去做一些就是资讯网上的一些拓展那样可能可以更好地去解决一些就是关键性的一些问题对那其实包括滴滴之前的一些那一个那个cabinol以及那个sinoz也是的其实包括我们现在很多的一些弹码就是包括像二人包括像
就是相丁克斯也是的对我们可能说很多里面有很多的一些就是一非要死然后去做判断然后如果说对于其他同学说那么他要写这么多的一个平台判判断的话那么其实对他对他们去构建业务的话其实是会非常痛苦的明白对因为我觉得这个问题其实我另外还有一个伪度想问就是因为我们其实那个直播间应该有一些高校的同学嘛其实我们其实更想知道就是说
比如说在你的职业生涯还没开始的时候比如说大学时候啊然后以及说你在职业生涯的前几年啊就是一年两年然后你还没有成为这个跨端方向的时候不知道当时你是在做一些什么的事情以及说你觉得那些阶段对你来说意味着什么ok嗯其实我觉得在职业生涯的一个初一阶段的话我觉得嗯还是一点我觉得就是首先就是要不断去做一些尝试不断的去做一些探索吧对
包括其实我们其实像我们对于公司内部很多的一些生动员来说也是这样子因为在处于直接世界的一个处理阶段来说的话那么一定要去不断的去看不同的一些方案去了解不同的一些原理对然后经过自己无端的摸索然后就是就是不要盲目的去听从就是其他的一些结论的而是通过自己的感受自己的一个实践然后去做一个摸索吧对这样的话可能说
长期来说可以去做一个个人的一个思想的一个观念的一个建设对个人的一个思想来说的话其实是一个长期的一个捶念的效果OK好的谢谢OK那刚刚有讲另外一个问题因为刚刚有讲到很多的一些发案嘛然后其实很想了解一下就是Links在当时为什么要做Links然后Links其实在整个字节跨平台体系中的一个定位是什么OK
对那么其实刚才讲到了就是其实整体上我们针对的其实是对于一些有较高确性能诉求的这样一个场景对以及一些就是重要的一些活动的页面去做了一个成改对那么其实并不是说就是所有的页面其实都是问题那么其实更多的一些像是和外部的也是和外部然后我刚才说了比如说一些像一些独立的小诉讼的话
那么他并没有那么多人力去做一些共产化基建的一些建设的话那么也可以用一些就是呃加了一些方案比如说像法特也是可以去更好去支撑他们的一些业务的ok ok 也就是说其实linkz本身他也不是一个万金油的角色对吧或者说是一个银蛋嗯他他说在当前的啊对他肯定不是一个万金油的一个角色对就是目前来说就是我们还是在
去做一个标准对极的一个阶段中我们目的是要去完全对极到前端的一个标准然后保证前端同学来说他不会说有太多的这样的一些就是非前端式的这样的一些体感对然后所以说我们也是在不断的这样的一个眼睛中对然后对于像一些外部场景那么我们也无缸也说其实我们现在也是有一些外部测的一些能力测疆方案
然后也是可以去比较适合他们去用的也另次取决的话说就是他可以就是通过 目前来说可以有一定的索耗但是可以保证页面的一个高性能展示对那么就对于业务来说那么可以取得一个很好的将来业务收益好的好的谢谢然后这就讲到这个点因为你确实有很多的就是可能你也讲到自己其实有很多方案嘛对吧然后可能很多时候这些
就是想了解一下就是比如说有的东西可能是有重叠的这记录方案他们的一些解决的问题的场景或说能力其实有有重叠的所以很想了解一下比如说你是如何看待这个我们大厂就重复造轮子这件事这个比较敏感的话题啊我其实我理解应该大家对这件事应该都是一个比较反感的一件事就是首先的话就是我觉得对这类事情的话是有一个基本原则的就是如果说
呃是一些底子那些基础能力的话那么就是应当的话就是一份基础的这样一些呃基础力建设对就不应该说同一份呃基础有多分对那么但是如果说是一些业务测的一些诉求那么他可能说嗯对于不同的业务场景他是有很多的这样的一些差异性的场景的话业务测去做自己的一些呃业务优化一些定制对那么这部分其实我理解的是呃是可以接受的对因为对于
像不同的业务方可能说像电商不电商广告直播对于他们来说的话他们其实对于可能对于同一件事他们有不同的一些那个服务端的一些方案或者说其他一些方案对那么可能说对他们来说一些业务策的一些定期优化那么这部分重复我理解是可以接受的对ok就说如果对所以说就是在一定基础上就是可以有一定的这样的一个重复
就是业务定制,但是要保证底层能力是完全一致。也就是说其实可能在我们的整套基础能力体系里面,它其实还是分层的,对不对?对,它肯定是一个分层架构,就是根据不同层,它会有不同的去适合它的这样一些方案,那么也不能就是一干个打死。
对那我其实很也想了解一下就是我们现在目前字节有这么多的体系嘛那比如说它的分层大概是什么样子然后我们现在到底比如说哪些能力其实是在可能比较基础的那些层面嗯ok呃其实那个对于跨平台引擎这部分来说其实呃你可以理解这部分目前没有那个重复到的因为我们这边也都是标明确去做那个我们这样的一个基础能力对
那么可能说其他的一些公司的一些功能可能说会有一些但是我理解就是确实我们之前也对接过一些可能说他们也是在不同场面下有些不同的一些诉求吧特别是可能说公司还有一个比较大的敏感就是比如说抖音的TikTok他可能说海外数据跟国内数据他是有一个隔离他可能说基础率不可避免的会有两头
好 这里我插一个问题吧因为有同学问的就是NICS的CSS现在支持的怎么样然后这个开发体验如何我觉得这个应该是一个前端的同学吧对 我们其实这部分一直在建设当中对然后也是尽可能的去也是目前是网络就是完全对起到就是达多三C的一个标准上在做一个建设对那么就是现在可能说确实是有一些
有些就是CSS可能說不對息的一些點的但是我們也是在盡量的去做一個建設不息然後我們也是對整體CSS的人體的一些就是解析的內容包括一些基礎內的話也是在做一些優化和改造的ok 其實這裡我有一個疑問就是如果我們要去對起那個什麼W3C的標準是不是這個框架會變得越來越重我只是先了解一下
可以可以说是确实这样子因为你多满足一个标签对那么其实都需要去呃作先让那个弹码的一个建设对不过呃我们也是在做一些就是刺客侧的一些就是加过了这样的一个梳理对然后可以保证就是对于这部分的一个死贷度的增加可能说尽可能的去做到一个减少对而且把手点掉
但我其实也在就是我们也知道其实我们对于跨端的框架比如说类似安安的框架其实国内有很多嘛对吧就是就不同的大厂或者说不同的厂里面其实都都带了这个东西对不对那有有很多我觉得好像他们的目标就没有说想要去对齐这个W3C然后然后因为不对齐W3C的话他就会比安安轻很多
对吧对但是我觉得这里其实这里面有一个问题就是你若不对及到这部分那个标准的话那么对于业务构建来同学来说那么他其实会很崩溃的就是他可能入职在你家公司然后你这边提供了一个方案给了他们去做一个业务的一个构建对但是这个构建来说对他他其实是会颠覆到他以往的将来一个就是开发
那么他肯定要去重新学习比如说他可能会重学那么你这个方案对那么但是那么他如果你起来他肯定是完全用不上的对很多的一些策略所以说对于标准一个建设其实我刚才也是放在我非常中一个非常重要的环节嘛就是必须要去就是拥抱到整体的这样一个社区拥抱到开发者对就保证就是
尽可能去兑取到整体的一个胆作三次那个标准这样其实对于跨平来说长期的眼睛它其实才是一个比较合理比较健康的嗯我明白这个这个我我大概理解了ok对ok好的那我们现在那下一个话题吧就是比如说最近的话因为现在我刚看了好像那个标业也提到一个叫做其他的那个我不知道那个是不是一个跨平台技术啊就我想了解一下就是比如说你最近比较关注的一些跨平台技术
最近比较关注可能说美团他们之前做了一个发那个尝试吧对就是他们做了一个基于Rust和Wasum的一个互联的一个尝试那么这个其实嗯怎么说呢他们其实是基于也是基于Renative吧他们主要是把那个Renative中间那个痛点就是他那个jess的那层给干掉换掉了就是也不是干掉换掉了最后他换成了wasum去做他的讯息
所以做它的一个相关的解释对然后以及逻辑之间然后去做它的一个水通性对那么用Rust去做它的一个业务逻辑代码的一个构建对然后上层的话它其实前段构建的话也是可以用就是那个Jetsar去写代码的对那么底层的话渲染的话它还是对老人远性的多方案然后在上面做技术的一个企业对其实我觉得这也是一个思路吧对其实它确实可以去解决掉就是
像目前来说就是RN的一个痛点问题吧对虽然说像RN他们最新版本上也是做了相应的一些优化方案但可能说最像美德他们的方案我理解的就是是一个突破的方案因为它可以用更高效的一个JS运机然后去做相应的事情好的好的请那下一个问题就是我觉得关于也是比较关于那个
比较个人的一个成长部分就是可能包装一公司了所以当时你是怎么进的字节我觉得当时是那个19年初的时候来的对其实当时来的时候人还比较少对其实整个资源研发团队也才2000多人的时候我还记得当时就是破3000人的时候当时整个研发群当时还有人就是庆祝了一这样的可能说当时当年呢说对整体的那个算法的可能会非常深入吧对
当时我记得是前两轮其实他都会有一道两题的一个算法题而且都是medium难度的所以说就可能说当时自己的一个面试也会被很多人喷就是算法吧当时有这么难吗都是medium的这种算法题当时就是一道两题吧包括当时我们整理一个面试标准其实可能就会对于算法的一个考察会非常的严格不过
也不是说就是长期吧因为目前来说可能说对于算法不会不会就那么严格还是说大家能够有一个基本的一个算法的一个思路而且就是有一个非常清晰的一个解体解体流程那么其实基本上也都是会没什么问题吧那对于这个你没有什么绝窍啊就当时还是说你原来就有比较好的基础嗯其实那个整体上大家我理解其实在日常的一个
这功能的话其实也都会去做一些那个做一些提升码的然后包括其实我觉得算算算码其实是可以去很好的去提升自己一个思维的就是去考虑到如何去解个题因为包括其实工作中也会有很多的场景会去用到包括像特别是说像快平台的话它会有很多的一些地步场景那么这时候要去做你比如说做一些地步做些便利那么其实都会
多少都会用到一些算法的所以说明显其实嗯多还是长的去做一些那个三个这样的一些呃练习我觉得应该都是挺好的ok所以其实就是你平时可能就有在做一些这种算法方面的一些训练嗯对之前差不多吧好的ok对所以就是这些算法其实对于比如说这种跨端研究的方向到到后面的话比如说渲染的部分其实是真的能用得上的
嗯 真的能上 因为特别是我们做快乐会更多的去接触到那个UI数嘛那么你怎么样去对UI数做一个那个便利怎么样去做更新那么其实这真的是用得着吗诶 这里有没有比什么比较推荐的一些类型啊比如说呃 因为算法题面确实可能有一些什么数形便利啊或者说是一些pice所有算法是是比如说跟图相关的一些一些这种算法题会比较有帮助嘛
徒论之类其实像数啊 项链表啊什么都可以我觉得我觉得而且也肯定也不用限制吧就因为算法的话其实也不能说就是你只会一两种数也够可能说多种数也够你都需要有一个基础的这样的一个了解ok ok明白但但我是感觉其实如果是数型的因为整个渲染数其实是数状嘛那其实可能跟数相关的一些这种类型的体验然后或者说是跟尤其是图吧徒论也有一些题嘛
因为我们以前做SN比赛的时候也有图论这样的一个比较细分的方向那是不是这个方向可以多尝试一些对 因为我而且我不知道比如说像数论这样的题或者说这种会不会有帮助其实如果说像面试的好我们也都会问可能说就是候选人对哪种数学课可能说比较熟悉因为可能避免就是要问到一些他不熟悉的相关一些数学课OK
OK,就却还想像那篇数据节目比较多一些嘛,就是但我觉得有时候比如像类似这种动态规划啊贪心相关的方向应该可能在这个我不知道在比如这个渲染的领域里面有没有一些帮助嗯,其实是有的,但可能说我觉得也不用举现在这些吧因为其实每一种算法它其实都是一种解决一个思路吧对,那么其实对于个人的一个呃就是思维的一个提升其实都是很有帮助的OK,OK,好的
我觉得直播间同学可以这个可以稍微去看一看当然我自己可能也很久没有去刷理的扣了那另外还有一个点就是因为字节其实可能我应该还是工程师文化的份还是比较浓厚的所以我想知道就是你们是用一些什么样的手段去建立这样一个比较好的工程师文化的呢这个可能对于一些相当来说小一点的团队也会有借鉴意义我是觉得如果我不知道bia可不可以做一些分享
其实我理解确实一个很好的一个很好的一个公认识文化其实对于团队来说其实会有非常大的一个帮助的嘛对那么其实我觉得最好的一点其实我觉得可以像优秀的学习的那么其实像那个整体像那个像Google吧Google他们会有非常好的一些就是公认识的一些文化的一个氛围吧对包括他们的一些那个技术方案或者说他们
整理上去如何提出一个idea那么将这个idea呃从提出到最终每一个时间到呃完成那么中间进了一些我觉得大家也可以去看一看吧对因为就是就是学习学习优秀的那个成熟的将有一些文化其实我的解决就够了也不用说自己去摸索一些对然后包括Google他们怎么去做课review然后怎么呃怎么保证就是技术方案的一个完美的一个落地避免就是
因为其实其实应该说就是国内很多公司的一个review其实很多时候就是个形式嘛对那当然就是点一点就这么过去了对并没有一个很好的一个可能的氛围或者说对于团队技术成长的一个提升那个氛围吧对结果理解就是嗯就像像google或者像一些公司学习嗯其实会有很好的一个帮助的嗯
谷歌我知道好像他们在技术文档处理上面有一个教室是类似是fc吗我不知道这个是不是谷歌提出来的我觉得这个就像我们这个是linkslabel来说也是这样子用的现在其实每要提一个需求那么其实也是需要大家去提一个fc然后去呃将相关的一个背景background然后目的然后解决什么问题然后呃长期维护然后testing所有东西都给考虑上然后
就保证能有一个非常清晰的对于一个方案的一个掌控然后保证是长期可轮踪然后讨论可记录这样的okok而这个可能后面看比较方不方便做一些比如说把一些链接啊分享到我们的那个群里面就是大家也可以看一下okok我可以补充一次就是估过了一些他们的一些成熟的一些方案做法吗嗯ok好的好的谢谢彼此
OK那这里还提醒大家就是去通过右下角加入我们的交流群因为后续因为今天这个分享我们觉得确实可能尤其是另一个部分不过现在太多就不会讲太多细节那大家如果是对于这个对于这个内容真的很感兴趣的话大家还是要进入我们的交流群方便后续长期的一个交流OK那我们今天就进入到我们整个访谈环境的最后一个问题就是作为一个跨端开发者那后续的话大概怎么样去发展会比较
就是可以更有前景一些的必要可以讲一讲你的理解吗嗯ok就是如果说是作为如果说是一名画平台的一个开发者的话我理解其实是后续到可能说因为包括有之前也谈到就是UI的一个构建的边界其实会越来越模糊嘛对那么其实原生开发者和前段开发者他整体的融合嗯会有一个进一步的一个融合的所以说我觉得可以大家打破一个边界吧就是
真相站在一个大前端的角度就是深入去学习前端然后就是以及对于扣端整体的一个呃就是就因为包括对前的东西来说就可以去更多去理解就是扣端为什么要去做一些就是呃内层啊或者其他一些管理控制对那么其实做一个融合我觉得对那么同时可能说呃也是要去可能说要去往更多的一些就是
标准上往更多的一些就是设计上去做一个拥抱吧就避免就是读造车然后造出来就是按自己所想的去呃实现其实对于呃使用的同学来说开发同学来说那会会觉得就很能用的嗯ok行那我觉得我们今天的分享呃内容就到这里吧